sur les réseaux sociaux vous êtes
notamment la cible souvent l'extrême
droite
comment vous expliquez cela que vous
faites partie des personnalités
politiques les plus contestées de ce
bord pas chez une femme donc
ç'a déjà saint
c'est important pour la fachosphère
je revendique eux
d'origine espagnole j'ai la double
nationalité blasphème donc je pense que
ça ça doit être quelque chose qui
je suis une femme de gauche m
je l'assumé maj jeu
chez leurs pratiques
je suis une femme qui porte l'écologie
un humanisme et qui dirige la plus belle
ville du monde donc je l'expliquent par
ça mais
franchement toute ma vie je me suis
engagé contre justement les racistes les
xénophobes les antisémites et les gros
macho je vais continuer